welcome back to a special edition of
tucker carlson tonight over the past two
decades american taxpayers shelled out
nearly 90 billion dollars for military
equipment for the afghan army that
included everything from an entire air
force blackhawk helicopters fixed-wing
aircraft hundreds of thousands of battle
rifles trucks armored vehicles now the
taliban has a lot of that equipment it's
one of the best armed militaries of its
size in the world the taliban
victor davis hanson is a fellow at the
hoover institution we're honored to have
him with us tonight professor thank you
very much for coming so the taliban
after 20 years
is more legitimate in the eyes of the
so-called international community and
very heavily armed much better than it
was
in 2001. how do you assess this
development
i think we're underestimating it tucker
if you look at all the military aid that
we've given israel since the founding of
the jewish state this is about 85
percent of that over 70-year period
we're all worried about the aircraft
carrier gerald ford 12 billion dollars
the most expensive aircraft carrier in
history we could have had seven of them
for the price of money for the price of
weapons that we've left in afghanistan
we talk about abram's tanks
the
the weapon depot that we left in
afghanistan has an equivalent worth of
three times of all the abrams tanks that
we've ever
we've ever deployed we've ever had in
the army and then finally we're all
upset about the f-35 fighter
the 90
million dollar boondoggle some people
think it is we could have had a thousand
of those for the amount of equipment we
left in afghanistan so this is the
greatest loss of military equipment
in the history of warfare by one power
it's absolutely staggering and yet we
take it so nonchalantly the people
responsible for this
should be
either fired or resigned they've done so
much damage to the united states
and they've empowered a
pre-civilizational
uh terrorist ban into making them into a
considerable you know militia that will
cause havoc for the next 20 years
and i think it's just
atrocious and nobody's talk taking any
blame for it this is well aside from the
7 000 scanners they left that they are
now using to find out who helped us
this is beyond the list of names of
people who wanted to get out that the
taliban have and the final thing tucker
is
we were told by a top ranking general
again and again that the taliban and we
had the same agenda we wanted out
quickly by the 31st they did so we could
trust them we were working together but
we didn't have agenda that was anywhere
near theirs because their agenda was we
want you out on the 31st
but we want to cause as much humiliation
death and destruction as we can get away
with so you don't come back and we
wanted none of that so there's something
terribly wrong with our military i don't
know whether it's their distraction
because of wokeness
as they go through the ranks and the
rosters trying to weed out potential i
don't know supremacist or they're just
incompetent
or they're too worried about the
revolving door going in and out from
defense contractor boards but we need a
bipartisan investigation of our top
brass and the system it's a systemic
failure and it's costing us dearly
possible the anglosphere is committing
mass suicide that's another explanation
because you're seeing it all over the
world from english-speaking countries
and that's
really good
viktor davis hanson thank you so much
for coming on
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else